Long before Kim Jong own became the
goto tyrants for five star absurdity.
There was another dictator on the block.
Muammar Gaddafi,
rude,
Libya for 42 years with an iron fist,
wraps in a sequin the glove,
so garish,
it would put liberace to
shame his flamboyant rain.
It was famous for its absurdity for
every headline relating to his terrorist
activities.
There were maybe a dozen more about his
plastic surgery addiction or his old
female bodyguard treat.
By the time Gaddafi
was overthrown in 2011,
he was less fit than he was simply mocked,
but behind the monstrous vanity lay,
a man who was simply a month
staff rape and Gaddafi's Libya.
It was institutionalized.
Mass executions were broadcast on TV.
Dissidence were executed,
and their bodies were kept in freezers.
For these self-styled King
of all kings to visit.
It is leisure,
but such depraved behavior.
It wasn't created in a vacuum.
It was only thanks to
Libya's tortured history.
There's good offi was able to
imprint his psychosis on his nation.
Today on biographics,
we're exploring the life of
the mad dog of the Middle East.
Most historians of Gaddafi
start with the obvious place,
the sweltering and June day in
1942 when he was born in a nomads,
tends near the dusty
fishing village of Santa Fe.
But to really understand Gaddafi,
you have to go back further all the way.